Okay, we're in the home stretch here. Let's figure out
how to build the HTTP request such that we can
pass all seven of these form elements. Now, the question
is where do these elements come from? In most cases
when you see form elements showing up that aren't obviously
part of the form itself, and by that I mean
aren't part of the user interface. Now what's gotta be
going on here is that we have hidden form elements.
So, let's figure out where they're at. So, here's the start
of the form. If, we look down through, I don't obviously
see any other elements. So, I bet it's in some of
this stuff that's zipped up here. So, let's take a look.
And, sure enough, right here we find three hidden form elements.
So, now we've accounted for six of the seven elements we've
got to pass along, the Carrier, the Airport, the Submit button
and then these three. And we can see that right here,
Viewstate okay, is one of those with a very long value. If I open this up, I see
that here we have one of those other values.
The other one in fact, that makes scrolling through all
the form data in the network tab such a
long and tedious process. Okay, so now we've identified
where all seven of the form fields are. The
question then becomes, how do we build our HTTP requests,
such that this data is included? Because that's really
what we have to do here. In addition to the
Carrier, the Airport, and the Submit button, we've gotta
send these along as well. So in this exercise what
I'd like you to do is write some code
here that uses the Beautiful Soup Module, and assigns values
to Event Validation and View State such that they
have the correct values. The values that this data source
is expecting to see come across. In a little bit, we'll talk about why
these values are necessary. For right now,
let's just focus on building the request properly.